so if you had some money what would you
do
i just want to be able to experience
things
[Music]
i just want to be free
hi
i paid 400 and it was never applied to
my balance
sorry how much uh interest is being
added a month
how are you
i need a real job just to like pay my
loans emily yo
let me hook you up
[Music]
in the next hour you will make 200 cash
but you will have to do something
illegal you won't be in danger but you
will be breaking the law yo you gonna
pay for that
sorry i said are you gonna pay for that
oh my god
sorry man
tomorrow you have the option to do
another job okay what do i have to do
you make that much selling tvs
sometimes tvs sometimes
other things you can show me how to do
it
none of this is safe
but if you listen to exactly what they
say you'll be fine
hello yeah it's still available one
second
you're scared of me
yes
hey
get out of the car
we're serious people
you should be scared of us
you told me it was a one-time team with
us i want my cut i just lost everything
people just keep taking from you until
you make the goddamn rules yourself
you know what my mistake really was
i didn't go far enough
you